[Musique]
mes petits amis
bonsoir vous avions promis une surprise
la voici c'est une belle surprise
une grande surprise c'est une surprise à
lourdes mais bien mignonne aussi se tut
surprise sur prise est bien nounours
importe vite notre surprise à nos deux
petits amis ce qu'ils vont être contents
mon échelle tabac surprise aux bonbons
bougie qu'il ait pas oublier les voilà
un brave enough
mais qu'est ce que tu as pas retenu
du calme le petit ouf que c'est lourd si
tu as beau me mettre à l'abri et des
mois les enfants ont la pause à plat sur
la table
doucement doucement là
soldes ou mardi dans ces grands ta
surprise oui qu'est-ce que c'est nos
deux vies du cd chocolat non c'est un
oiseau
bon ça ce mage au pouvoir alors c'est du
sirop de framboise ou il ne pense qu'à
manger ses enfants allons poser moins de
questions chacun votre tour à toi pas
preneur ce héros bon c'est pas car et
wallons j'ai trouvé ces des cubes mais
nicolas nounours tu viens de te dire que
c'est pas carré qu'est ce qui lie à
lagord et les déficits surprise nous
nous passer pour un chat parfois je suis
pas un chien non maison apple foule a
aidé mais aussi wii bien noir et bien
brion y voilà ils boivent du lait et ils
sont sages et bien élevé ce sont mes
petits neveux shérif ajoutant aussi car
on va bien s'amuser
il faut les papilles
oh il dormait le chérubin toujours aussi
mignon mais oui vous pouvez donner vos
cadeaux à nikolay a pas preneur
[Musique]
on ne sait si philippe tizon nicolas et
pimprenelle ont été bien gratter
quelques autos d'eau douce elle n'en
prennent plus le soir le matin seulement
attention nous avons maison
[Musique]
partons sans faire de bruit nounours
tout notre petit monde dort déjà autres
on se couche très bonne nuit les enfants
bourret
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]